you're considering two people for a job
one pretty one ugly in achievements
they're equal who do you hire the pretty
one no the ugly one they accomplish just
as much while having a bias against them
always factor in other people's
prejudices I think what's interesting
about this one is we hear so much about
white privilege we hear so much about
male privilege but we don't hear about
the Privileges which actually and
experimentally have a much greater
influence on life outcomes and those are
pretty privileged they are more likely
to be hired in job interviews they are
more likely get higher earnings they are
more likely to have the door held open
for them this is particularly true of
attractive women because men tend to
judge people by their appearances more
than women do so I mean attractive women
are some of the most privileged people
in the world but unattractive women are
some of the most unprivileged people in
the world or for a man like the depth of
their voice leaders are more likely to
be elected if they have deep voices or
if they're taller but we never hear
about attractiveness and how much of a
privilege that is